Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. I'm your host, Rawkode.
Today, we're gonna be taking a look hands
on introduction to c plus plus Now before
we do that, there's just a little bit
of housekeeping.
First, if you're not subscribed to the YouTube
channel, I would encourage you to do so
now. Subscribe and click the bell, and you
will get alerts for all future episodes of
Rawkode Live as we explore and learn this
vast cloud native landscape together.
If you're not watching live and wanna come
join us in the chat, there is a
Discord server available at Rawkode.chat.
Come in there and say hello. We talk
about all things cloud native, Kubernetes, rock music,
and a whole bunch of other things in
between. So we look forward to welcoming you.
Now to guide us on our journey into
c plus plus today, I am joined by
a c plus plus developer advocate at Microsoft,
Cy Brandt.
Hi, Cy. How are you? Hey. Good. Thanks
very much for having me. How are you
doing? Very well. Thank you. And it's a
pleasure to have you here. I've seen a
few of your talks over there the last
year.
All very very interesting and exciting and
very low level at times. But I think
those are those primitives are really good way
to try to understand
really
complex topics as well. So I'm very,
very excited to have you here today.
Can you do us a favor? And just
for anyone who is not familiar, hasn't seen
our talks, doesn't follow you on Twitter, give
us the introduction to Sai.
Yeah. So my name is Cy Brand. I
work as Microsoft c plus plus developer advocate,
where I spend most of my time on
Twitter just, like, making nonsense.
My background is in,
compilers
and, debuggers, tool chains for for graphics cards.
I spent about five years writing,
like, GPU compilers and debuggers,
which is where I got, like, fascinated by
really
low level stuff.
And,
yeah, that's where my kind of love for
developer tools and things like that came from.
So then I've been at Microsoft for for
a couple of years now and,
still, like, giving talks about c plus plus,
getting involved in the
ISO standardization.
Like, I just got a
feature hopefully getting into c plus plus 23,
which just got approved a couple of days
ago. So I'm very excited about that.
Awesome.
Okay. Well, we got people saying hello in
the chat. Hello, everyone, and welcome to today's
session. Everyone.
You also like to explain low level concepts
for viewer cats, and you have your own
YouTube channel. I will include a link to
that in the description, but you wanna tell
us a little bit more about that if
you want? Yeah. Sure. That was basically
I I come from, like, a very traditional
background of computing. Like, I did a CS
degree.
I
have been programming
for since I was, like, 10 or something.
So I I, like, come from, like, the
traditional background.
But then when I went into the industry
and started working with people who come from
different backgrounds and saw how they saw things
and explained things differently,
And it was sometimes a lot more digestible,
a lot more understandable the way that they're
approaching things. I wanted to try and, like,
join those two things together, like, bring
all of the the knowledge and interest I
had from, like, low level concepts, from my
experience with compilers,
and from from my degree and things like
that,
and take different approaches to to trying to
explain these, like explaining with household objects and
my cats and whatever I happen to to
have around. So that's Yeah. The odd child
toy, I think, has popped up there and
again as well. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I
explained hash tables with my my kid and
some teddies, and the the hash function is
how cute the teddies are.
Awesome. Which is a terrible hash function.
It makes it fun and entertaining. We'll learn
on these concepts. You know, I think you'll
do a lot of credit for producing this
content and material. It's a it's a joy
to watch.
Okay. Now you've got your biggest challenge of
all which is to introduce me to c
plus plus a language that I haven't played
with in in many many years.
But I wanna I'm gonna give a shout
out to one of my former colleagues, Stuart,
who works at Influx Data. He kept telling
me for years now, go and look back
at c plus plus because it's not the
c plus plus that I'll remember. Like,
he had many good things to say about
the evolution of the language. I think you
just mentioned that version
c plus plus 23 is now a thing.
So like,
I'm curious and excited to see some of
these new constructs in the language and and
how they're gonna
hopefully
improve it to me. I think my image
of c plus plus back, you know, and
let me clarify. This has come back at
least fifteen years, think. So to me, it
was the difficult language. Having only ever done
Perl and c at the time,
I think now, hopefully, with my experience, it's
gonna be a lot more familiar and easier.
But he's always had said really good things
about modern versions of it, so I'm excited
to learn that today.
Okay. Let's
jump over to my screen share.
We are using
Exorcism
today. Are you familiar with Exorcism at all?
No. I had, like, a brief look,
but, yeah, I've never used it before.
Yeah. It's a a really cool project that
has, like, language tracks. In fact, let me
just quickly do the thirty second pitch but
It has language tracks. A lot of tracks.
Yeah. It says here showing 50 and I'm
assuming there's maybe Yeah.
I love the x 64 assembly
I
kinda wanna do that one. I haven't done
that much x 64 in a while. That
would be cool.
Yeah. It's it's it's a nice website for
picking up on your language. It kinda guides
you through a bunch of different problems
that start with like really easy things like
hello world and simple challenges which normally involve
working out leap years, etcetera, but then they
go down to more difficult things. And that
kind of guide through the language would be
cool enough on its own.
But you'll see here it also says there's
mentors. And all that means is that when
you submit
your solutions to problems is that the mentors
generally review them and give you feedback on
how you can write more idiomatic code in
that language. So it's a really Yeah. Interactive
way of learning as well.
Yeah. I think that's really, like, valuable thing
as well because there's there's getting the right
answer,
and then there's having a solution which is,
like, actually edematic and maintainable and performant,
and those can look very different. So, yeah,
having that mentorship on top sounds like a
really good thing.
Awesome.
Well, I think we should start with hello
world. I think it would be rude not
to.
That's good. I have a local directory here
where I've already downloaded the hello world example.
I have my Versus code open,
and I've got the basic files here that
we need to get started.
So let's open the README. Probably a good
place to start.
So our objectives here, and I like that
it always kind of lays out what we
wanna do. The other nice thing about for
people that aren't familiar with it is they
provide tests for all of the examples. So
your goal is actually
to make the test pass, which means you
get introduced to testing in the language as
well as writing code, which I think is
really important.
If we pop open our test, I have
never seen a test in c plus plus
before, so this is exciting.
Okay. So this is using the catch two
testing framework, which is probably
the most popular
testing framework for for open source projects right
now, I would say. It was developed by
Phil Nash,
and it's
yeah. It lets you have these, like, quite
nice requires
statements where you just say, I require that
hello world hello is equal to to hello
world rather than, like, some other testing frameworks
where you'd have to say, like, require equals
or require true or things like that.
Okay. So
this makes sense to you then as a
test case.
Good. Good. That's good. And is this is
this the test framework you would use as
well in in your This is what I
use for my my open source projects as
well. Yeah. So that that test case in
in case is
this is a test case, and it's called
test hello.
In fact, one of the cool things about
catch is that you don't need to use,
like, c plus plus,
identifiers
for your test case names. You could call
that test hello as
as two words if you wanted. You could
use special characters in there. You can do
whatever you want. And then you can also
it also takes a a tag so you
can, like,
up your tests into different tags and and,
like, run large subsets of tests. So you
want to, like, run only the, like, command
line driver test or you want to only
test, like, some part of your application, then
you can do that with catch. So it's
it's quite nice.
Okay.
Well, I mean, there's one thing that's jumping
out to me right now that is that
is confusing me is that at first, I
thought these were function calls. But I noticed
that the test case here has then got
braces after it, which makes me think it's
maybe not a function call. Right. Exactly. So
these are macros.
Macros in c plus plus is
essentially the same as c macros, if you're
familiar with them. So they're
the and the the idiom is to use
all caps when you when you have a
macro because macros can do weird things,
which normal, like, c plus plus functions cannot
do. So bringing attention to the fact that,
hey. This is a macro. Pay attention. Something
weird might be going on is why we
use case.
It's like how how Rust uses the the
exclamation mark or the bang after the macro
name just to draw attention to, like, hey.
There may be dragons.
Yes.
Okay. That makes a lot of sense then.
Well, these are macros
making writing tests easier.
Yeah. Exactly. I've got one more question. This
is not really related to the test case
here, but
is there now, like, a de facto way
in c plus plus to pull in libraries?
Like, is this pulling in a cache library
through a package manager or something? Or
That's a very good question. So, basically, we
are
so c plus plus was originally standardized in
1998,
like, a very, very, very long time ago
when,
like, dependency management
was not a thing which, you know, all
languages just had, and they had great solutions
for handling your dependencies and saying what your
dependencies were and what versions they were and
things like that. But C plus plus is
having to to evolve. So there is no
standard dependency management
tool,
nor
de facto or DigiArray.
There are a few solutions.
The two major ones are Conan
and vcpackage.
Vcpackage is
is the the Microsoft one, so it's the
one that I'm most familiar with. Okay.
So this,
I can't tell what this is using
just
by okay. It looks like it's literally just
using the the header only
version of CAPS. So, yeah, when when you
when you cloned this directory,
it just has a copy of the CAPS
testing framework in it. So it's not using
any dependency management stuff.
Okay.
Well, that that's good to know.
That makes a lot of sense. But I'm
keen now that we jump into our hello
world. Like, we've got the test. I understand
this. Require is like an assertion and c
plus or at least in the catch framework.
We're calling our hello function, and we're expecting
to get the string hello world back.
Yep.
If we look at our code
okay. This looks a little bit different from
what I remember.
So the good thing is I remember they
include pragma.
I do not remember
namespaces or using keywords.
Cool. Well, I can walk through, I guess,
from from top to bottom kinda makes sense.
The very first thing at the top there
that hash include hello world, this is how
you bring
other functions
or names or or types from other files
into
your your current file, essentially. So c plus
plus, just like c, has,
things split up into implementation
files like this one, which is a a
dot cpp file, and header files, which are
dot h or sometimes dot h p p
as well. Different people use different things. But,
basically, the the header files are a description
of the types and functions which,
you can call and use, and then the
implementation files
are, you know, the actual implementation of those
things, what the the actual code does rather
than how you can use it. So the
this hash include just brings everything in that
helloworld.h
to to make it available in this file,
and it literally does do textual inclusion. So
when when you do a hash include, it,
like, literally takes the entire contents of that
header file and dumps them into into this
file.
There are in c plus plus 20, which
is the the most recent version of c
plus plus has a feature called modules,
which,
is a more like, if you're familiar with
modules from from other languages, it'll be a
little bit more
more reasonable. It doesn't just dump in entire
text files. It, like, actually looks at the
the symbols and names available and exports them
in in sensible manners. But this is this
is using the the old style, and I
I think the version of Clang you're using,
which is the the compiler, doesn't support modules
yet. So so we can't use modules. But,
anyway, modules will make this better.
Anyway and then the the using namespace std.
So std or std is the the namespace
where everything in the standard library lives.
So std string is the standard library string
implementation.
So when you say using namespace std,
that says,
okay. If I type
some,
unqualified name just like we do later on
where we say string and we don't say
std string, we don't say some other namespace
string,
if I just say string, then I want
you to look in the the STD namespace.
It's basically a way of stopping you having
to type
the namespace.
I will say that it's
probably not that idiomatic to using namespace std.
Some people do do it, but,
generally, I like to make it obvious when
I'm using something from the the standard library
Sorry. I guess it's to my own code.
Idiomatic to maybe just do this and not
pull in std?
Yeah. That's that's what I would prefer to
do, but it's you can do either. The
the main thing is to not write, like,
using namespaces in the header file because then
that will get copied into everyone else's files,
and now you're, like,
looking for standard library names when you maybe
didn't want to.
You know? In fact, I just noticed this
comment here, which is actually telling us that
we could Absolutely.
Yeah. Do that as well. Okay.
So that's when we say when we say
names
on line five now, when we say namespace
hello world, this is defining our own namespace.
So
everything in the standard library lives in the
std namespace. Now we are saying, okay. Everything
inside these braces is inside the hello world
namespace.
So this is just a way of, like,
qualifying names so that, you know, if I
have a function called hello and I include
some other library which has a hello function
that they don't conflict with each other.
Is that mandatory?
Nope. So you could just completely get rid
of namespace hello world and the,
the closing brace at the end, and you
would just have a an unqualified
hello function, which lives in the global namespace.
Oh, okay.
So you can do that, but you shouldn't
because then if someone else does that, then
everything goes horribly wrong. Plus our test does
seem to fully qualify it here. So Yeah.
I guess I should And the test could
just like we had earlier, the test could
say using namespace hello world, and that would
be a very, very reasonable thing to do
in your in your test suite. If you're
gonna be using all the names from your
own, library anyway, then,
then you could just write a names using
declaration like that.
Okay. Awesome. That's great context.
I'm gonna make a wild assumption right now
that just changing this to hello world is
probably gonna pass my test.
Yep. Can we walk through the process then
of confirming that? And then we do have
a couple of questions on the chat that
I'll get to in minute just a minute,
Daniel and Kai.
So Sure.
I've modified this. I think my test is
good. I'm assuming I jump to the command
line,
go into the directory,
I'm presented with
a CMIC list dot text, which I'm not
entirely sure what that is. I'm sure I
could read the read me, but do you
wanna just give us the TLDR on building
this thing?
Sure. So just like with
with dependency management, there is no standard build
system for c plus plus. However, CMake is
essentially the de facto
build system nowadays.
It's what most c plus plus projects use
for building.
So it's essentially a
it's its own language. So if you if
you, like, look at the CMakelists.TXT,
that's a description of how to build your
project, and it's written in
the CMake language.
So we have things like,
yeah, this add executable command
that is
saying how to build the the executable for
our project.
And you can see further down where it
says set target properties. That's saying, oh, we
want to use c plus plus 14 as
our
as our version of the standard, and we
don't want
any
extensions,
like,
we have compiler extensions from Clang or GCC
or whatever compiler you're using. So Is CXX
the way to that always mean c plus
plus rather than CPP? Yes. Alright. CXX is
the way that the it's the the the
term that that CMake uses, which is
what, like, Auto Tools used as well, if
you ever used Auto Tools
back in the dark ages.
It's quite a lot
to build Hello World.
Yeah. This is not, like, all
like, if you wanted to have an absolutely
minimal thing, all it would literally need is
a minimum
CMake version
and
and project
specifier and an add executable. Like, this whole
thing could be three lines if Alright. They
wanted it to be, but they're probably doing
other things. You know, like, they've got stuff
stuff to run the tests later on and
and whatnot. So Yeah. I I guess this
is just one of those things that as
you start to work with more c plus
plus and get more acquainted with the tooling
and stuff, it all becomes a lot familiar,
I guess, like any other language.
So So if we want to build this,
then the the usual thing you would do
is you'd make a directory called build,
and then change dir into there and then
run CMakespace.
Dot.
Yep. So CMake is a
it's not actually a build system. CMake is
a meta build system, which sounds kinda weird.
But, basically, it's a because there's so many
different ways to build code in,
you know, in Windows or in Linux or
Mac or BSD or whatever you're using,
CMake generates
a build system for you. So if you
use,
like, Visual Studio, then CMake could generate a
a Visual Studio solution. Here, you can see
it's generated a Makefile.
Nowadays,
most a lot of people use Ninja, which
is another build system.
So, yeah, this is the the Makefile which
is generated for you. So now if you
run Make, then it will build your project.
I know make. That's that's something.
Yeah.
Alright. And you can also run c make
dash dash build dot, which
will will do your build step regardless of
what generator
you're targeting.
We had a capital letter mismatch.
I broke my code already. Alright. So we
could change that back.
Well, we're changing the test instead of the
code. What did I? Yeah.
Is that not no. Of course not. Right.
Okay. That's
what I do if my code doesn't work.
I just change the test until it pass.
There we go. Yay. A testy hello world.
Heard you that
oh, no. That did run run the test
as well. Yeah. Because the the CMake lists,
yeah, had a a target which ran the
tests for you. So nice.
Yeah. So our default target here runs all.
Yeah. Generally, you don't wanna look at the
make file that
generated,
but you can if you want and it's
just it's it's not pretty.
I know. We let's not do that. I'm
more interested in the language itself,
and we'll touch on bits of the tooling
as as needed. But so far, so good.
It's
all starting to come together. It's probably a
good picture in my head. Hopefully, also for
the audience too. But I'm gonna So that's
how you'd use CMake list from the the
command line. Also,
Visual Studio Code has
CMake
extension as well, which makes it that you
can just build from from
from within Visual Studio Code.
Oh, cool.
Yeah. I I don't need to think that
right now. Let me read out these questions
for you. I'll let you tackle them in
whatever order you want, and then I'll get
the next exercise ready.
So Kai starts off with a, hopefully, a
nice simple one, but Kai is curious of
how do namespaces differ from classes.
Yeah. So Sorry. Oh, yeah. You go for
that, and then we'll come back to you,
Go for this one.
So a namespace is just a way to
split functions and classes
into
digestible
units in a way which they don't the
names do not conflict with each other. You
cannot have,
like, an object which represents a namespace. Like,
you can't create,
an instance of our hello world namespace. You
cannot pass them around or do anything like
that. It's just essentially a prefix
to,
any names which are inside those blocks. So
whereas classes, you can,
create an instance of one. You can pass
one around. You can give it
data members. You can give it
functions which you can call on instances of
that class. Namespaces are just named prefixes, essentially.
I guess if we were to correlate that
to Go, which I think Kai has a
a better familiarity with, then namespaces would be
like packages and classes would be like structs,
which also happen to have methods on them
as well. I think Sure. I don't really
know go, but that's interesting.
Alright. Daniel seems to be jumping straight into
the deep end, I'm afraid, with his first
question. But Mhmm.
He's saying a lot of folks in the
cloud native community are just a Go
Mhmm. Which, unless you're using GCC Go, pretty
much has one compiler.
Can you maybe talk about some of the
trade offs of the various c plus plus
compilers?
Absolutely.
So
the
main
compilers which are available for c plus plus
are
Clang,
which is the compiler which
OSX uses
and is also available on Linux and now
Windows.
GCC,
which is the
the good new c plus plus compiler. So
it's the the one which is kind of
the default on most Linux systems.
MSVC,
which is the
the Microsoft c plus plus compiler as that's
the the team that I'm on at Microsoft.
And there's also ICC,
which is the Intel c plus plus compiler,
but it's not quite as common.
So
as far as trade offs and differences between
them go,
they're
all good at different things,
And
which you target is
sometimes related to which platforms you will be
targeting, Windows, Linux. Quite a lot of projects
will target multiple compilers.
So, like, if you're
if you're building for Windows and Linux, then
maybe you're you're gonna target MSVC for Windows
and target GCC or Clang for for Linux.
If you're writing a generic library, then you
probably wanna make sure that your code will
compile
on all of those platforms.
If you are targeting just one specific compiler,
then you can do,
like, more aggressive optimizations.
Or even if you're targeting multiple compilers, you
can write code which will, you know, do
certain things on with some compilers and use
certain things on other ones. So there's there's
a lot of different things you can do.
Alright. Awesome.
I didn't realize there were so many compilers.
Yeah.
Okay.
Hopefully that answers your question,
Dan. Now we have cloned our second
exorcism
tutorial challenge. I'm not sure what we call
them. But it wants us to determine if
a word or a phrase is an isogram.
An isogram is a word or a phrase
without any repeating letter,
however spaces and hyphens are allowed to appear
multiple times.
I did not know what an isogram was
until three seconds ago. So there we go.
Yeah.
So is it wait. Is it adjacent characters
or is it just
okay. Now it's Yeah. Think it's Yeah.
If the the character appears twice
anywhere
in the string, then it's not an isogram.
Okay. Oh, yes. Okay. So, yeah, isograms
is
not an isogram because the s is on
it twice. Okay. So, yeah, we can't have
any any letter twice in our word or
phrase.
Yep.
So we already have I'm just gonna start
with the test cases here. We've got empty
string. That makes sense to start with. And
we're expecting to get a true value back
because spaces don't
count.
I find it curious
that they actually define and expect it as
a billion, and I'm not sure why it's
got braces for output and then have the
assertion. Is is that idiomatic?
No. No? I am kind of confused why
they did this as well.
So and and as far as that that
line 12 goes, that
so maybe we can talk a little bit
about about variable declarations
in general. Yeah.
So the the variable declarations here on line
ten and twelve, they both begin with const
bool. So bool is the boolean type.
Const says that this is an immutable
variable. So try changing this will not compile.
If you do some shenanigans in order to
get the compiler to accept you changing it,
then it's undefined behavior,
and your program may blow up.
So
right at the start, we have the type
of the variable, then we have the name
of the variable,
which is actual in case of line 10.
Then we have,
the equal sign and an initializer.
So
actual will be initialized to the value of,
returned by the function isogram is isogram.
Now on line 12,
this uses
slightly different syntax
for,
declaring
a variable.
So this is valid.
It's not really idiomatic.
Like, I would just use equals true there
if I was going to be.
Yeah. Yeah. Either having require true equals actual
or just having expected equals true. Yeah. Exactly.
I I see very, very little reason to
use braced initialization there. Braced initialization,
you mostly use if you're initializing,
like, a a container, like a
an array or a vector, and you want
to give it a set of initial values.
You know, like, you you want an an
array of zero one two three, then you
would use braces and write zero one two
three in those braces. There's no real reason
to use it in this case, I don't
think.
Okay. Well, I'm just gonna remove that one
because I I I don't understand it. In
fact, I don't even Sounds good to me.
This one. Like, that to me seems perfectly
acceptable.
Mhmm. Okay.
So let's see what code they have given
us to work with.
Matter. Not a lot.
Alright. So it's expecting an is isogram function
which takes a string.
We have a namespace already.
So I'm assuming
I've got maybe I should disable Copilot.
Is that is that cheating?
Alright. So we're we're gonna be returning a
boolean. Right? Because we're
okay. So now now we can maybe talk
about strings a little bit as well.
So there is a few different string types
in in c plus plus. If you go
back to the test
Yep.
So
anything enclosed
in
double
quotes, like that, is a string literal.
So
that's any string which is embedded into your
program. The type of a string literal is
a constant character array.
So this string literal will be a a
constant array of one character because they are,
they're null terminated. There's always a a null
character at the end.
But
string literals are
well, arrays in c style arrays in c
plus plus are a little bit weird because
they can change to pointers. We generally try
to shy away from them. So in c
plus plus, the main types we use for
strings are std::string,
which is
a string which owns its
own data. It has
buffer stored inside. It can be modified. It
can grow.
And the other type is std string view,
which is
actually, if this is using std string view
is a c plus plus 17 thing, so
it might not even allow us to use
string view. But string view is essentially a
a view into some existing string. So we
don't own the the memory. We're pointing at
some memory which is stored elsewhere, and that
could be a string literal or it could
be,
like, an existing
std string
stored somewhere else that we're just referencing into.
If you're familiar with Rust, then it's like
a
std string is the capital
s string,
and string view is like
a ref stir.
Okay. Yeah. That does make sense. The
the rush string stuff, I understand. I didn't
know it was so similar to the c
plus plus one, so that works really well.
Now Yeah. Is it string
view? Is that what you were seeing there?
Like so? Yeah. So that is what
would ideally be used here. I think
wait. I mean, we we can try it,
and if it doesn't compile
yeah. It's already saying that's oh, wait. We
we'd have to include the the header for
it. So, yeah, up there, we do hash
include.
And then
so there's there's two different syntaxes for hash
include. There's hash include yes. Exactly. That's what
we want. There's hash include double quotes, which
looks for the things in our own project,
and there's hash include
angle brackets, which looks for system include
headers.
So we would hash include string underscore view
just the same as string view, but without
the std. Yeah. Exactly.
Oh, it's happy. Okay. It's happy. We'll see
if we'll see if it builds.
Okay.
So what we wanna do is isogram.
Yeah. So our our first test case is
just empty string. So I'm assuming if we
have an empty string, we're just gonna return
true.
Yeah. So we could say if stir dot
empty. Oh, empty. Okay.
Yep.
Exactly.
Like so? Would that work? Yep. All good.
Mhmm.
And I guess we need a default case.
That's good to me. I just add don't
I don't see any red squiggles, so
that usually keeps me happy at the start.
Alright. So I would make a build directory.
I would run c make dot dot.
Mhmm. And then go.
Yep.
Okay. So I got something wrong.
November is isogram and namespace.
Isogram.
Did we, go into the header file?
So, yeah, we've got isogram dot c p
p. We also got isogram dot h, so
we need to declare
our,
our function here. So Would you just copy
and paste the sling?
Yes.
And end it with a semicolon.
So this is saying that
somewhere,
nebulously, there exists a function called isogram,
colon colon, isisogram,
and
this is the the header file which people
will include into their program in order to
know that there's something we can call call
this. And then when we compile the program,
then the linker is gonna, like, work out
where this function is actually defined.
So is it fair to make this
like, any function defined inside of a namespace
is essentially private until we add it to
the header file, and then we're making it
publicly available at that point in time? Alright.
Okay.
Yes. You can think of it that way.
It gets a little bit there's more details,
but, yeah, that that's a mental model which
checks out for
the the basic cases. Yeah.
So if we run make now,
then I'm getting under or so I didn't
use Okay. So in the in the header
file,
you need to also include
string view.
Alright. Okay.
Yeah. Because the header file needs to know
because it's taking a string view as a
parameter, it needs to know, like, what the
the size of that is and
how to pass one around and things like
that. Well, because this includes dot h, do
we still need the string view here? No.
You could get rid of that. Okay.
Alright. I was compiling a bit longer this
time. That's probably good.
K. They're still past. Okay. Awesome. Nice.
Let's see what our next test case is.
Now it looks like it's using
is this macros? Would you call them pragmas?
I'm not sure. Macros. Yeah. Macros.
I'm assuming I could just remove that, and
that would bring in this test case. Or
Yeah. I think there's
probably something defined in the CMake
which defines that, but, yeah, you can just
get rid of it as well, I'd say.
I'll just move it down. I'm assuming that
brings in one test that I I don't
know why it's still grayed out. Oh, there
we go. Okay.
So now
it really likes that brace syntax, I'm gonna
say. Yeah.
Now we wanna call isogram on isogram. Okay.
So now we're gonna actually have to do
our first bit of actual
code. So I think we're gonna need
to be able to loop over
each of our characters and just store them
in an array. So maybe we could talk
about first how do we define an array
to store scene characters.
Sure. So are we how are we gonna
be
doing this? Are we are we gonna be
only
assuming that our string is ASCII
and
then
counting if there's more than one
Yeah. I think each, or are we gonna
use a hash map? Or there's a few
different ways we could do it.
Yeah. So
let's do a hash map and then if
the key exists, we'll just immediately return false.
Otherwise, we'll continue to loop over and store
them. And, yes, we'll stick to ASCII. There's
already been a joke about UTFE
based on another series I do called clustered.
I'll talk about that later.
No UTFE.
Okay.
Yes. The UTFE story for c plus plus
is is a mess.
Yeah. Let's let's take the ask you then.
So first of all Yeah. Like, how do
I define
a hash map then to be able to
store the scene characters?
Yep. So the the default hash map
in c plus plus for reasons
is called
std unordered
underscore map.
Like so? Yeah. That's it.
So unordered map
is,
we'd have to include the the header for
unordered map as well, which is,
it's just called unordered map.
Okay. So we want to do an include
on our yep. There we go. I feel
like these ones should be above the string
ones. Is that something you would do? Or
Yeah. Okay.
I'm sure if it's like a whatever. It
doesn't matter. But Yeah.
So unordered map is a class template.
So templates in c plus plus are
the
the basic way to do generics.
So if you're familiar with, like, traits from
Rust or, like, Swift protocols
or,
Java generics or whatever anyone else calls them,
it's it's kind of a a similar thing.
So you can't just create an unordered map.
You have to create an unordered map with
some key type and some value type.
So in this case, our unordered map is
going to be a map from,
characters,
which are char, c h a r,
to,
I guess,
just
Yeah. If we're if
we're doing a char to to build like,
if if we're just checking if we've seen
it before, then we actually actually don't need
an unordered map. We could do it with
an unordered set.
Yeah. Because that's just
checking whether it exists yet or not.
Yep. Exactly the same.
So we would just have it on our
the template
syntax?
Yep. That's the template syntax.
So,
yeah, so for for our declaration,
we would need to say,
stood unorderedset
will be the first thing in our declaration
because that's the type. So we'd say std
unorderedset
char scene
semicolon. Yep. And that will construct an empty
unorderedset,
and
that will be our our scene
object.
Okay. Cool. So
the first thing popping into my head now
is when we call dot empty, which I
didn't know was possible on the string view,
I'm assuming we can get
the characters or an iterator or something we
can loop over as well through a function?
Yep. So
we could do that by by calling functions,
but
c plus plus has the the idea of
a range, which is
basically
the beginning
of some range and the end of a
range, and those two things are called iterators.
So anything which supplies a begin and end
function is a range in c plus plus,
and we can loop over things which are
ranges a lot easier than anything else. So
we can use what's called a range based
for loop, which is like a for each
loop or for in or whatever you might
know from from other languages.
And so the syntax for that is just
for
and then parenthesis.
And then we need to say what the
type of the thing we are looping over
is. In this case, it will be,
characters,
so just char.
We need to give it a name, so,
I guess, just c.
Yeah. Letter.
And then
colon.
And then what we're looping over, which is
str.
Yep. So this reads for
character c in
string,
do whatever
is,
is within these braces.
Okay. So I'm assuming we can do scene
hat? No. Contains?
.Contains,
I believe, is
I don't remember what the the interface for
We
have find. Maybe we should just find.
So find will will return
an iterator.
There is contains, but it says that's in
c plus plus 20.
We can use dot count.
So if you
yeah.
Would that not return the size?
Yes.
But current dot current will Oh, current. Sorry.
No? No. No. It's dot current. So we'd
see scene dot current and give it c
as the
as the argument.
Yeah. I've got two dots in there.
Yep.
Yeah. So this will
because it's
an unordered set, then current is gonna either
return zero or it's gonna return one.
So Right. Okay. Gotcha.
If in c plus plus
yeah. That that will that will be fine.
Yeah. So that that will check to ensure
that
c is not in scene. I'm just gonna
make this up now, but I'm assuming
we could do this.
I think this is gonna do an early
return, although I could be wrong. And I'm
assuming here,
could we continue?
Yeah. So you could do that. I generally
try to not use continue in loops because
it makes them very difficult to to read.
I would
instead
use
put an else clause after the the if
and
and do a return false in there.
Yeah.
Okay. Well, it looks like it's complaining about
my for loop. Let's fix that first then.
Did I get something?
Looks
fine. Maybe try and compile it, see what
the compiler says.
Okay. That compiled just the test. Yeah. Think
okay. Just my Versus code then.
Yeah.
Okay. So we are ranging over our string
and pulling out each character.
Mhmm. If the count for that character is
zero, we're going to insert it. If it's
not zero, that means we've seen it before.
It is no longer an isogram, and we
return false,
which now means if we get down to
here, we're actually return true. An isogram.
Look at that. There we go. Nice.
Then we can, I guess, uncomment the
other test because there was another one?
I don't think we may have a a
bunch. But Yes.
I think just get get rid of that
if
I think, and
there'll be
matching one right at the end.
Oh, there's a lot of tests. Yeah. Get
rid of that end of let's just see
if they all pass.
Alright. Failed.
Alright.
No. We don't handle there were some exceptions
here. So it said
hyphens and spaces are allowed. So I guess
if we just quickly add
Yeah. A condition to not look to skip
over them.
Yep. So
if c equals
this
So
character so things enclosed in double quotes are
are string literals. Things enclosed in single quotes
are characters. Yep. So we want we want
that. Yep.
We could say if if c equals hyphen
or c
equals space,
you could do it in the the same
I was just saying in the in the
same thing you had.
Oh, yeah. We don't want to insert this,
do we? Okay. No. Yeah. Just have another
yeah. Perfect.
Yeah. And then you've got a a trailing
Yep.
Yep. So in c plus plus, double bar
means
you can also
just write or. That works as well.
Nice.
I quite like it. A
lot of people don't because No. I think
it reads well. To the double bar. I
think it does as well. Yeah.
Okay.
Should I continue in here or should I
just
do nothing? Yeah. You can write a continue
in there. But
because we've got the change conditional, so we
should be okay just doing that, I think.
Yeah.
Maybe. We'll see. The test will tell us.
Oh, okay. So two edge cases.
It's not really given me
mixed case.
So we have to lower case it.
And
the last one
is also just the mixed case thing.
So.
Yeah. So we could use
std to lower or std to upper, just
a normal case. Part of the range, or
would you create a new variable?
Yeah. You probably wanna you could just you
do c equals to lower c.
That's all one word, to lower. It's a
can't remember which header it's in.
Split to lower
is in the c type
header.
Okay. How would you work that out? C
c type.
I'm sorry. Say that again, please? It's c
c type, two c's at the start. Yeah.
It's a that's an old c thing.
Yeah. You would generally work that out just
by going to CPP reference,
which is,
I'd say, the best online
c plus plus reference website
and just typing in the function if you
want, and that will tell you what what
header is. Yeah. Exactly. That's it. Okay.
Oh, I forgot my semicolon.
I have format it, which is just an
indicator that my code is maybe alright.
And all of our tests Yay.
Okay.
There's quite a lot
to kind of unpack here.
So
I like the unordered
set. You said we also had maps. So
there's all of these built in data structures
for handling, I guess, most of the common
use cases.
We got the range
for
Mhmm. Which was cool. Like, does c plus
plus have
functional primitives for doing this? Like, you know,
the ability to maybe map, filter,
etcetera?
Right. So
prior to c plus plus 20, there there
are these things called algorithms,
which are in the algorithms header.
And
those are
kind of what you're looking for. We have
things like transform,
which is basically a map,
lets you run some function over all of
the elements in some range. We've got, like,
remove f. We've got,
like,
couple
two or three dozen
algorithms
in that header. Yeah. The problem with those
is that they don't compose very nicely. You
have to essentially have, like, intermediate data structures.
So, like, if you wanted to do a
transform followed by something else, then you would,
like, transform
your string into some other string and then
operate on that. C plus plus 20 has
ranges which compose.
So you could, like, build up a pipeline
of operations and say, like, okay. We've got
my string. I wanna transform it. I then
I want to filter it. Then I wanna
drop the first three, then I wanna do
this, then I wanna do that. And those
would all only they would happen lazily. So
only when you ask for an element do
all of those operations actually occur.
But the the version of the compiler you're
using does not implement those yet.
Okay. Awesome.
Alright. I'll throw one more question out because
this
just something I've been curious about. Like, my
very old knowledge of working with c and
c plus plus required a lot of mallocs
and the allocation.
We haven't had to do any memory management
yet. Now is that just because our types
are mostly primitives or just because c plus
plus handles some of this for me?
So,
basically, if you're
so in in c plus plus
like, see, we have malloc. C plus plus
has new.
If you're writing c plus plus and you
use new to allocate memory in 2021,
you're probably doing something wrong.
You
gen generally, we try to avoid
allocating
a dynamic allocation as much as we can.
If we do have to allocate dynamically, we
try to manage that allocation
with
some standard container, like, unorderedset
here. Unorderedset is doing allocation internally
and not exposing that to us.
We could, if we wanted to, supply our
own allocator and do a bunch of ridiculous
stuff. But for, like, 99.99%
of our use cases, then,
this is just gonna handle all the memory
management for us.
If we do have to do our own
memory
management now, we would not
use new and delete,
because
as much as people say, oh, simply remember
to to call delete, like, that that doesn't
work. So in c plus plus 11,
they introduced smart pointers,
which are essentially
help you do memory management. So unique pointer
is the main one you would use. You
would create a unique pointer, and when that
unique pointer goes out of scope, it calls
delete automatically, so you don't need to remember
to do it.
Awesome. Thank you.
Okay. Let's tackle a couple of questions from
the chat, and then we'll try and squeeze
in one more of the extra system ones.
But let's see. Oh, Mozz. Hey, Mozz.
Oh, there's an interesting question. Hi, everyone. I
saw after goal, there would be no need
for c or c plus plus. Oh, come
on, Mozz. No. We're we're actually seeing a
good uptake of c plus plus in the
cloud native community. I think primarily driven by
Envoy. I'm not sure if you're familiar with
the project, but it's a a network
proxy.
And the reason I think Envoy and other
projects are now starting to use c plus
plus is for a lot of performance reasons
over
at Go. So no, Mozz. I don't think
Go means we don't need it. I think
there are definitely a lot of use cases
out there. I I don't know if you
want to add anything else to that or
just leave it at it. Yeah. Definitely. Like,
I think that what c plus plus gives
you is
full control over the layout of your data.
And and and you're aware, like, cache performance
is,
like, one of the most important,
areas of of optimizing your program,
then having the ability to do that is
super important. So, like, thinking about how your
data is laid out such that
it makes the most of the cache, such
that you don't have,
like, multiple threads contending over that
can just give you incredible
performance boost. I remember once, like,
this was for for a GPU, but
adding a single no op into
a loop,
improved performance
by 10 times because it made much better
use of the instruction cache, things like that,
which you just cannot do in in so
many other languages that don't give you that
much low level,
control over how you layer your data and
how it's it's used and cleaned up. Yeah.
That's a lot of projects that even are
using
Sego a lot of the time to bring
in some of this other stuff too. So
definitely very popular.
Okay.
Ben Woman is asking,
does c plus plus have an official or
unofficial documentation or reference site? Yeah. Basically, c
plus CPP reference is the
the de facto standard is the one which
most people will go to.
Alright. Carlos suggesting that Infinidash is written in
c plus plus I've
heard rumors otherwise, but we'll see.
Russell is asking,
are there any sites to find out a
duomatic c plus plus?
Good question.
I
think there's there's one called CPP
patterns
or did it change its name?
I'm just looking it up.
Yeah. CBP patterns.
Second one. Yeah.
Yep.
This is a decent one.
It tells you what
version of the language
it allows, things like that.
Doesn't look like it's been updated for C
plus plus 20.
But,
yeah, things like this,
going to Stack Overflow, like the usual kind
of places you would look.
There's also the the hash include c plus
plus Discord,
which is a Discord community for
c plus plus focused on making, like, a
welcoming, inclusive environment.
That's always a great place to go and
say, like, hey. I've got this this code.
Is there a better way to do this?
There's always people there willing to to help
out. Why don't we flip that question a
little bit then? You know, you're you're quite
involved in this c plus plus community. So,
like, what are the the bigger conferences that
maybe people can check out some of the
talks that are coming out?
Sure. Like, the biggest one is CPP Con.
I just so happen to have this, like,
right here.
Yeah. CPP Con is usually in September. It's
gonna be October this year.
It usually has, like,
six, seven, eight
tracks, runs for about a week. It's a
it's a pretty big conference.
I think I gave
four talks there last year. Oh, wow.
One year, I gave I gave five talks
and,
like, helped run a panel and things like
that. I would not recommend doing that. It
was exhausting. Sounds like a stressful week.
Yeah.
Yeah. That's c b p con.
C plus plus now is probably the best
one for,
like, expert level content.
And then the smaller ones like c plus
plus on c,
CPPP,
which is the c plus plus Paris,
the Madrid c plus plus Spain one.
There's a bunch of of smaller conferences as
well. ACCU
as well has a bunch of really great
c plus plus content.
Right. Definitely no shortage then of c plus
plus content. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And the the
conferences are only growing as well. Like, there's
new obviously, not right now, but previously, there
were, like, new ones popping up pretty much
every year.
Awesome.
Okay.
Let's use the next kind of fifteen minutes
to maybe just tackle one more of these.
We won't go through all the test cases,
but maybe if we can pick something that
shows off a little bit more of the
language. Is there any features you would you
think would be nice to show and we
can try and find an exercise that uses
them?
Talking about
type inference would be good, but I feel
like we can build that in pretty much
anywhere.
Let's see. What about Nothing involving randomness, so
that I don't have to explain randomness in
c plus plus.
It says pattern recognition here. Is that pattern
matching?
For it. There is not pattern matching, but
at least we can we can talk about
that and
and what might be coming in the language.
Yeah. Okay. Well, let's see what we can
kinda make of it. Even if we go
a little bit off script, that's alright. So
let me
clone this one.
Jump over here. So what is it asking
for?
Once does to generate the lyrics of the
song, I know an old lady who swallowed
a fly.
Not a song I'm familiar with,
but it's a cumulative song of unknown origin.
Yeah. I have no idea what this is
asking.
Yeah. So I think the the song is
usually like you you have a line and
then in the next verse, you repeat
that line and then add a line. And
then in the first after that, you repeat
the first two and then another one. So
it's it's like building up
the song.
Okay.
Let's see if they give us any code
to start with, and then we'll make a
decision.
Yeah.
So we got our test case here. We're
expecting a string.
Alright. Okay. So we're calling the verse function
and we're giving it how many
verses we want out of our new lines
added to it, I guess.
Yep.
Let's see what we have. Oh, we get
nothing.
So it's a maybe we could just make
it up. Like, it doesn't matter if the
test pass, but maybe we can talk about
pattern recognition and maybe we can talk about
type inference as we go. Are you comfortable
kinda just making this up? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
We can just make something up.
So the
yeah. Type inference,
why don't we just make a function
which doesn't do any return anything? Just we've
got something to play with. Yeah. Void means
I'm a function which which doesn't return anything.
Void is like a special type in c
plus plus It's
not quite a unit type if you're familiar
with the concept of unit type, but it's
the the
closest that c plus plus has, basically.
So so type inference in c plus plus,
like, previously, we've been declaring variables
by writing their type and then a name
and then an initializer.
You can also write auto
instead of a type. So if we write
auto here,
and then
name, yeah, equals
yep.
So this will based on the type of
the initializer,
will deduce
a type for that variable.
So this uses the same rules as as
templates
do,
which is kind of nice in in the
way that the it's like that this came
in c plus plus 11, kind of reused
a lot of the the existing rules in
the language.
But, basically, when when you're using
more complex c plus plus, you end up
with really, really, really long types.
You know, it might be like a
vector of
the iterator
types
for a vector of integers, and you don't
wanna write that type yourself.
So
we now allow you to write auto
in there, and it will work out the
type from the initializer.
It's
not like Rust in the it will, like,
look how you use
the the variable
downwards in the function. You know, like in
in Rust, you can say, I have a
this is a vec,
and later on, you, like, assign an int
into it, then it, like, looks forward and
says, oh, later on, you use an int,
so this must be a a vector of
of integers. And c plus plus is has
to be
based on the type of the initializer,
but it just it cleans up so much
code. And you can use this in
in range space for loops as well. Like,
earlier, we wrote char c,
which was the the type which we were
iterating over. But you could just write auto
there, it will work out for you.
So you're saying we could have done
auto c
name
Exactly.
Yep. And then whatever the
okay.
Yep. It seems to be complaining
about my supposed to type as missing and
assumed.
Yeah. But when I hover over,
is that just my editor again, maybe? Yeah.
I think it's just your editor. The the
compiler would be happy with that. Okay.
Oh, maybe something else we can talk about
is references.
Yeah.
So
if we
well, we write two functions.
Yeah.
And make that one take a string.
Yep. And then
write another
function
called, yeah, whatever.
Another one.
Some other. Yeah. Okay. And make that one
take a Std string ref, so ampersand.
Oh, ampersand. On the variable name or before
the standard string?
It's yeah. After standard string, it can be
it doesn't matter which side of the space
you put it on. Oh, okay.
Yep. So
these are
two different functions. Another takes the string by
value, which means that the inside another hello
is some completely new string, which is completely
separate from
any of the context outside the function. So
if we pass, say, our our name from
inside our hello function, the the David thing
into another,
then
nothing can ever happen to that name.
Yeah. It will be the the copy inside
of another is is something completely separate.
The version of some other, however,
has the ampersand
after,
after the string. This will actually not compile.
I'll get to that in a second. But,
when we put an ampersand after a type,
that means that it's a a reference to
that type. It's not,
a copy.
It's
like an alias for something else.
So in c plus plus references are mutable
by default. So if you pass
some string into some other, then some other
could, for example, change the first character of
of the name, or it could append
some additional data onto it. This is how
you,
you can, like, mutate things while passing them
around functions. And then if you wanted to
make it a
reference but you cannot change it, then you
would do const
std string ref,
in in the declaration of some other.
Okay. Mind if I ask a few questions?
Yeah. Go ahead. Okay. So if I hover
over David here, it's kind of the type
of inference is maybe suggesting that this is
a const char six,
but it doesn't seem to mind me passing
that as a standard string. Is there some
type juggling happening here? Yep. So
c plus plus has
implicit
conversions,
which is basically, in some cases,
you can
pass,
you can initialize,
some object with an object of a different
type.
And as long as there is some conversion
function
which can convert between the two implicitly,
then it will just work, and it will
do some magic to to convert it. And
there's a few different ways that you can
specify
those conversions.
So converting
a,
string literal to a std::string is one of
those cases where there is an implicit conversion
function, which will,
take the contents of the the string literal
and copy them internally into
a std::string, and that will potentially
allocate some memory dynamically,
which will then be freed when the std
string is is destroyed.
Right. Okay.
So if I were to implement my own
type in c plus plus and I wanted
to be able to convert it to a
string that would just be implementing a function
on Exactly. Right. Okay. Yep. And
implicit conversions are a little bit contentious because,
you know, in some places like this, they're
super useful. Like, of course, you wanna be
able to convert a
a string literal into a string. Like, that's
something which is is really useful to do.
In
some other places, like, they seem like they
might be ergonomic. They might make things easier,
but you can run into to issues where
you get, like, inputs and conversions where you
maybe didn't want them, and it can cause
some some additional errors which are really, really
difficult to see because, like like you said,
you you see that you can pass this,
thing of a different type to another function,
and it just works. Some some magic happens,
but it's not obvious that there's a conversion
happening here. You you have to know
that
the that these two types are different and
if there's some way to convert between them
to know that there's a conversion happening, it's
not clear from looking at the code.
Awesome.
Alright. I'll throw one more. We don't need
the code up anymore, I don't think, unless
we wanna jump back. But I'll throw one
more question at you just because, again, I
have curiosity.
Like, we've been now writing c plus plus
for a little over an hour,
and we haven't typed a single class.
Is
that normal in modern c plus plus that
you use maybe just functions within namespaces,
or does it just, again, come down to
the domain that we're actually building something out?
Yeah. It definitely comes down to the domain.
A lot of the power of c plus
plus comes from the ability to
create your own
to work at the level of your domain
without having to pay,
runtime cost in order to do that. So
what that means is creating your own types,
which express, you know, your
your business logic or whatever you wanna call
it,
being able to write templates which abstract,
common behaviors of your types,
being able to
create,
code which
can sometimes read, like, the operations you want
to do, but will, like,
compile to a bunch more code under the
hood.
But you don't have to, like, handle that,
but it will happen in a way which
is
which still gives you the performance that you
need. So the the the common term that's
used is zero overhead abstractions
Yeah. Which is another, like, slightly contentious term
in the community. But, basically, it means that
being able to write code a high level
of abstraction without paying undue performance cost.
Awesome.
Well, thank you very much for joining me
today. It's been really good fun learning c
plus plus. I'm really glad that we can,
you know, understand or dug into the tooling
a little bit. I had no idea about
CMake.
Really cool to see the way the tests
were structured and then just a few nice
implementation details of just to
acquaint myself with the language. But I I
feel like I understand things a lot better
now, and you've been into quite a fair
amount of detail on some of those features
features as well. So I just wanna say
thank you very much because it was really
good fun. Yeah. Thanks for having me. Alright.
Well, you have a wonderful day. Thank you
again. Thank you to our audience for watching.
Do you have any last words before I
I say goodbye?
No. I think
if you're interested in,
like, learning modern c plus plus, I would
have a look at,
Kate Gregory's Pluralsight courses. They are are really
good and
teach, like, modern c plus plus,
for for beginners in a way, which I
really like. There's a bunch of really good
books,
like,
true c plus plus is now updated for
c plus plus 17, I think. I can't
remember how much c plus plus 20 is
in there.
But, also, if you're, like you've done c
plus plus before and you are interested in,
like, how c plus plus 20 will change
things,
I'm really interested in, like, making good resources
for this because we're we're still in the
the education phase of this. Like, c plus
plus 20 is kind of new, and it
comes with a lot of really new,
like, big features which can really change the
way that we write c plus plus. Like,
we we talked about ranges and being able
to compose these in in a way which
you might be familiar with from from other
languages, like chaining iterators in Rust or whatever.
So, yeah, keep your eye out for resources
on that, and let me know if there's
anything that you're particularly interested in because,
yeah, I wanna, like, make good stuff on
this.
Alright. Well, I will make sure I include
a link to your YouTube channel and to
that Pluralsight course and all of those other
super plus reference websites that we mentioned at
the session. They'll all be in the description.
And thank you again. Have a great day,
Cy. Yeah. Thanks. See you. Bye.